[Musique]
deux fois par semaine c'est compliqué
donc l'eau on arrive que deux fois par
semaine et à partir de quelle heure une
heure deux heures du matin ou plus 3h
on est obligé de réveiller les enfants
parce qu'on peut pas sortir à une
certaine osseuse à cause de l'insécurité
on est obligé de prendre tous les
enfants de la maison aller avec les
boîtes les boîtes qui sont là dehors à
la fontaine où vous étiez
[Musique]
très dangereux pour la santé cependant
la saison des micro qui monte on n'a pas
de choix parce que j'avais des enfants
il y a des gens qui sont des familles de
minutes qui n'ont pas de moyens pour se
projeter le minéral ou d'autres
personnes je suis obligé d'aller dans
d'autres quartiers
[Musique]
et je suis Alexis
il n'y a pas d'urgence qu'un pays comme
le Gabon là où là où il y a de l'eau et
on manque d'eau au niveau des robinets
c'est pas c'est qu'il y a un véritable
problème c'est que la société nous et
l'énergie du Gabon ne comment lirage ne
prend pas vraiment ceci à cœur
[Musique]